this video is sponsored by brilliant
when I visited New York for the first
time in December 2017 I was lucky enough
to see the city in the snow well I say
lucky after 30 minutes of magic seeing
the Christmas trees and the skyscrapers
in the snow I realized that I was
actually incredibly wet and cold and can
I please go back to normal please but
also it's not all of that lucky to see
the city in the snow a statistic I was
subsequently told was that New York gets
more snow than the South Pole but how on
earth could this be true the South Pole
is one of the coldest places on earth
it's the point in the middle of
Antarctica famously full of snow and New
York well New York looks like this in
the summer so I downloaded some data and
took a look unfortunately data on the
exact South Pole is hard to come by
partly thanks to extreme isolation and
partly thanks to the u.s. government
shutdown currently locking me out of
NOAA datasets thanks so I had to find a
comparable statistic for New York to
this set from the German meteorological
offices records of the South Pole
research station here the measurement is
average millimeters of precipitation per
month I couldn't compare this to
precipitation from New York as that
would also include sleet hail and rain
while the South Poles precipitation is
to all intents and purposes exclusively
snow so I downloaded data of snow depth
from the ECMWF the units of which are
millimeters of water equivalent or the
depth of water you'd get if you melted
all the snow the time series of New York
snow depth from 1979 looks like this
with clear spikes every year in the
winter to approximate the snowfall each
day I looked at the difference between
subsequent measurements if the
difference between snow depth on two
days was positive then there was
snowfall on that day if the difference
was negative then there was snow melt to
get the total snowfall in a given month
then I simply summed up all the
differences between days whenever that
difference was positive I will be the
first to admit that this is a pretty
janky approximation even with six hourly
resolution but the best I could do with
what was available but whilst there is
an approximation importantly this method
produced a data set which as far as I
can tell produced data with the same
units as the measurements taken at the
South Pole if he plot the snowfall
precipitation from the South Pole and
compare it to the estimated data from
New York
there's no contest New York by my method
gets a hundred and seventy seven point
three millimeters of water equivalent in
snow precipitation on average each year
the South Pole gets 2.1 millimeters so
how to get snow falling on the ground
you need two things you need moisture in
the air and you need freezing
temperatures in the atmosphere from the
layer that the snow forms at down to the
ground the South Pole absolutely has
that last point covered with the warmest
average monthly temperatures being about
minus 25 degrees Celsius every day is
cold enough for snow this is possible
because the South Pole receives the
least energy from the Sun of any point
on the Earth's surface apart from the
North Pole is very reflective meaning it
doesn't absorb much energy from the Sun
and is in the middle of a giant
continent Aries in the middle of
consonants have a much greater
difference in temperature between summer
and winter than areas near the ocean
this is because water has a much higher
heat capacity per square meter than land
meaning that it takes much more energy
to change the temperature the ocean
compared to land you can see this both
on a seasonal scale with oceans barely
feeling the effects of the seasons while
continental areas roast in summer and
freeze and winter but also on a daily
scale this animation shows the surface
temperature of the earth over a few
weeks you can see the effect of the Sun
heating the land during the day which
then cools at night while the ocean
stays a nearly constant temperature this
provides a moderating influence on the
land near the ocean it calls the land in
summer and warms it in winter however
the South Poles distance from the ocean
whilst guaranteeing frozen temperatures
year-round also prevents it from meeting
the other criteria necessary for snow
moisture in the air if we switch
variables in this animation from surface
temperature to total precipitable water
in the air we see that Antarctica is
incredibly dry a strong zonal
circulation prevents moisture from
further north reaching the continents
and almost all the water on Antarctica
is frozen and blocked in even on the
rare occasions that moisture does reach
the interior there's another problem
while water can freeze and forms snow
crystals on its own it's much easier if
there's a source of nucleating centers
things that water can freeze on these
include biological sources
black carbon like soot and plain old
dust
there are very few sources of nucleation
centers at the South Pole meaning that
even when moisture does reach that far
south it finds it incredibly difficult
to actually form snow crystals these
difficulties are so great that in terms
of precipitation Antarctica is actually
the desert the largest desert on earth
by contrast New York is right on the
coast and so has a warmer climate but
still experiences extremely cold days
check one more importantly New York has
ready sources of moisture the Atlantic
Ocean but also the Great Lakes the Great
Lakes lie to the west of New York and
the prevailing wind in New York comes
from the west meaning that the lakes
provide a great deal of moisture that
when the conditions are right in winter
can form snow so yes New York does
receive more snow than the South Pole
but then that's not all of that
impressive London receives more snow
than the South Pole the end of the earth
may be very cold but it's also very dry
thanks to a meteorological isolation and
being so far from the ocean the wind may
move snow around on Antarctica and bring
it to the South Pole but it's very rare
to see new snowflakes falling there if
you enjoyed these animations of
geophysical data then you might want to
check out Planet snaps on Twitter a bot
I coded which automatically generates
visualizations of the earth every couple
of hours I've never done any coding
based on web interactions before so this
project was a real learning experience
picking a project and learning how to do
things along the way has always been the
best way to learn a skill like coding in
my experience which is why I'm super
happy to say that this video was
sponsored by brilliant brilliance is an
educational website that emphasizes
learning through solving problems
presenting you with new theory before
testing your knowledge as with my case
learning to code my bot it's absolutely
ok to get stuff wrong as long as you
learn from your mistakes and don't get
disheartened you'll get there in the end
something that brilliant reminds you
brilliant has a series of courses
perfect for those wishing to learn how
to program including a course on Python
the language are used coming soon I'd
recommend doing what I did on my bot
learning a little bit each day and
consistently pushing yourself to solve
new problems to do so go to brilliant
org slash Simon Clark and the first 200
of you to do so will get 20% off the
annual subscription to view all their X
causes thank you for watching the video
if you found the science and this one
interesting then definitely check out
the crash course that I made with dr.
Tom Dowling who helped advise me on the
script for this episode all about the
science of the cryosphere don't forget
to check out planet snaps on Twitter and
thank you very much for watching I see
in the next one